[Music]
well u.s stocks closed slightly higher
after the fed raised its key interest
rate by three quarters of a point the
most aggressive rate hike in nearly 30
years now it's an
effort to tame it record inflation
higher interest rates make it more
expensive to borrow money meaning people
will eventually spend less leading to a
drop in demand for goods which should
lower inflation so what does this mean
this means less buying power for
consumers especially those looking for a
home joe muller spoke to one home buyer
about her plan moving forward
i want to buy a house so i'm in the
market for a home right now rosetti
gutierrez ue was getting ready to buy a
new house i am worried about the
interest rates i wish i would have
bought sooner she says interest rate
changes will mean she can't get what she
initially thought now it's like crunch
time for me so i don't want to
you know wait a little bit longer
because it'll be a you know 200 to 400
difference in my monthly payment in an
effort to cool the economy the feds
adjusted the rate this now means people
don't have as much buying power when
looking for a home a few months ago they
were able to get a three percent
mortgage and today it's somewhere around
six percent or approaching six percent
they simply can't afford as much as they
could before economic expert brian
gordon is a principal from applied
analysis he says this year we have seen
multiple hikes he says this could play a
role in home prices and rent prices
going forward the reality is it's higher
than it was and so from many people that
may make the difference particularly
those
be looking to get into their first home
he says interest rates in the single
digits is still low when looking at
rates in the past it's very scary
especially if you're not familiar with
it gutierrez ue says being in real
estate herself she thinks it is still a
good time to move forward when comparing
it to the changing rental market at the
end of the day rent is
100 percent interest and you know it
it spikes
and you can't
guarantee that it won't change joe
muller live local now